when we first started like talking about
this kind of stuff back when your
Channel first started and you'd bring it
up I would be like so like taken aback
when you'd say how the court system is
more in favor of a woman but it's really
true I mean imagine women get custody 90
of the time imagine if that was flipped
and women only got custody 10 of the
time they would say they would say oh my
God like women are being discriminated
against they can't even see their kids
but like for the vice versa nobody bats
an eye and it's just it's just kind of
crazy because like men don't even really
complain about this stuff yeah something
to think about it's eye-opening isn't it